ancient Mesopotamia often called the
cradle of civilization showcased
remarkable vegetable gardening practices
the fertile land between the Tigris and
Euphrates rivers allowed for advanced
agriculture Farmers utilized irrigation
systems diverting river water to their
fields enabling year- round
cultivation they grew a variety of
vegetables including onions garlic and
lentils crop rotation was practiced to
maintain soil fertility alongside the
use of organic fertilizers like animal
manure ancient Mesopotamians also
implemented tools like sickles and plows
made from wood and metal their deep
understanding of seasonal cycles and
plant needs laid the groundwork for
modern agricultural techniques
showcasing their Innovative spirit